so Mark Norman oh wow going right in I
don't know no intro no nothing
have we ever met I don't think we've
ever had a conversation maybe a hello at
a club or something but yeah that's
comedy you know you're La I'm out here
but were we in new faces at Montreal the
same year oh maybe like 2012. yeah with
Pete Davidson yes Christy yeah yeah yeah
that was a big year Big Year it's all
downhill after that actually oh Even
Rick Glassman was that year oh and I
remember I got a bad review
this like reviewer loved Rick Glassman
and hated me and maybe that's why I
don't like Rick anymore for all this
time um did you have a good experience
at the Montreal news I did I had a great
time I got a got a manager I got laid
Yeah I had a great time that was the
manager I [__] him but yeah good times
I love Montreal just a fun city and that
used to be a fun fest now it feels kind
of like it's fizzled out okay so that's
the last time I saw you
you look exactly the same thank you so
much so much you look younger
you guys liquid death's new Iced Teas
are available now with free shipping on
Amazon and at retailers near you trash
Tuesday listeners get 20 off your first
liquid death apparel purchase available
exclusively at liquiddeath.com trash
that's liquiddeath.com trash for 20 off
they're very cool one-of-a-kind apparel
you know you're stewing over a health
problem you have you almost resort to
texting your group chat to get your
friends opinions don't do that you guys
go to zocdoc.com trash and download the
zoctalk app for free then find and book
a top-rated doctor today many are
available within 24 hours and that's
zocdoc.com trash
lumi's starter pack is perfect for new
customers it comes with a solid Stick
deodorant cream tube deodorant two free
products of your choice like a mini body
wash deodorant wipes and free shipping
as a special offer for listeners new
customers get five dollars off a Lumi
starter pack with code trash Tuesday at
Lumi deodorant.com that's Lumi
deodorant.com and use code trash Tuesday
for five dollars off your starter pack
this show is sponsored by betterhelp
visit betterhelp.com trash Tuesday today
to get 10 off your first month that's
better help
h-e-l-p.com slash trash Tuesday hey
sluggies I am here in beautiful Toronto
I'm so sorry I'm missing all of these
New York episodes I was
I was out sick with cluster headaches
but I am now on steroids and ready to
party you can come see me live on the
welcome to Annie Woods work next stop is
is North Raleigh North Carolina
Raleigh North Carolina May 11th and 12th
uh that's gonna be with Josh Potter
coming to that one
um I'm then going to be in the movies in
the beginning of June in Baltimore you
can see me at uh uh Wise Guys in Salt
Lake City also with Josh Potter I'm
gonna be at the end of the month I'll be
in San Antonio at the LOL Comedy Club I
also have a lot of dates planned that
aren't up yet I'm gonna be going to
Philly Austin San Francisco San Jose a
lot of things but go to
annieleterman.com shows to get your
tickets and then every Thursday
every Thursday at 12 p.m Eastern 9 A.M
Pacific you can come to anniewood on
YouTube and watch my solo podcast we got
a lot of amazing guests it's going to be
so incredibly fun we also do a live chat
on YouTube so come check it out
hi slugs I am on tour I'm going to be in
Boston New York City Atlanta and Raleigh
you can get tickets at Esther onice.com
I've been here in New York working on my
standup I cannot wait to have fun with
you guys at these shows I will see you
get tickets at astronice.com
[Music]
I watched your interview with Neil
Brennan and I want to say that this
might be like a companion piece to that
all right we're lucky so I wanna there's
something I'm gonna list for you a few
things that I want to talk about
you grew up in a dilapidated Mansion in
New Orleans yes
um you've wet the bed oh yeah being at
Women's places big time
um your wife met your parents and it
validated for you how weird they are yes
this is great you have sleep problems
big time okay a lot of these are things
that I relate to all right so I'm like
ready to go okay you're you're my
parents won't talk to you either
what your parents don't talk to no I'm
just kidding but they're they're a
little they're a little distant okay
they just doing their thing I'm doing my
thing okay so that would actually
already validate something that I'm
suspect of where you're were you
emotionally neglected as a child I think
so I mean I want to say they're good
folks yes never yeah never molested they
paid the rent and put food on the table
but uh I think they're just kind of
Southern waspy Workaholics they just
went to work we watched Seinfeld at
night and then we did our own thing wait
that's very similar except not waspy
Workaholics but okay so
I recently I've always felt like I had a
really like a pretty good childhood and
I've always said that like I was watched
not raised meaning like they kept me
safe like they knew where I was but no
one really interacted with me and like
they even like took me to dance class
and like you know if I if I wanted I was
like oh I want to try tap dance like
they drove me there but I am always like
why is there this hole inside of me and
I recently learned it because like my
emotional needs were not met like one
time my fiance was like you just seem
like someone like when you were a little
girl no one ever spoke to you wow do you
feel
like you're a little girl who's never
been spoken to I'm Anne Frank no
um yeah I guess but I I don't know I had
a bunch of friends I was never home I
was out skateboarding all day or at a
sleepover so I made it work yeah but I
never felt like we could talk we never
had a birds and the bees or any of that
[__] yeah yeah okay same in fact when I
asked my mom where babies come from she
said I don't know whoa yes that's crazy
yeah so and I also always was sleeping
over places and me and my older sister
like once we both got boyfriends we were
never home like always with a boyfriend
or always with like friends um Okay so
it's crazy to me that you grew up in a
dilapidated man in New Orleans mostly
because I've been to New Orleans once
and it was like the exact opposite of
everything I've ever experienced in life
like it so doesn't even seem like it's
in our country yes I noticed there's a
few memories I have please one there's
like a bad smell on most streets yeah a
lot of urine and vomit two
uh the old houses seemed scary just from
like walking past them yeah they're
terrifying and then the third was I
thought the cemeteries were like at
least very cool and creatively inspiring
yeah wow good notes so if I was scared
of these Mansions from just walking by
were you scared living in one of them
all the time and there's not we don't
believe in street lights in that City
it's weird because it's like this
touristy City where everybody's coming
in from Cleveland and all these places
so you'd think he'd light the [__]
place up we'd like to not get mugged and
the crime is through the roof so yes
terrifying we had a house alarm that
would go off at like two in the morning
and as a nine-year-old you're like well
there's somebody in the living room
that's just weird you know you're on the
second floor and they're below you then
you come down in the morning to get
breakfast before school and the TV's
gone are you serious yeah so it was a
little
it was a little jarring I think that's
why I'm so skittish
but uh you got used to it you know and
like when the alarm would go off we had
a connection to the police like it would
trigger the police so they would call
and if you said Batman my parents made
the the code Batman so we us stupid kids
could remember it and so the police
would go and you go Batman and then we'd
hang out and go back to bed and Batman
man everything was fine Batman meant
We're Not Dead
were you then awake at night like
listening for scary sounds like you
couldn't sleep like because sometimes
I'll be in bed I'm like is that a sound
like yeah did you have that all the time
oh my God and I think I I walked in on a
few robberies not walked in but saw them
happening and that was pretty scary and
I think I have a repressed memory
because I think about this all the time
this is so crazy because our house was
so dark and Dusty and [__] up that
like I think I saw a guy at night in uh
in like a little tucked away like hiding
and I I think I blocked it out and just
went to bed and now every time I go to
my apartment I have a tiny apartment I
check every closet I check under the bed
I'm convinced there's a guy in my house
all the time this is so insane
it's like so hard for me to understand
that someone who grew up in a
dilapidated Mansion in New Orleans like
how did we end up in the same career
like of course we seem so different but
also
I feel like I am afraid of the same
things but I you actually like
experienced it like I was always afraid
someone was breaking into the house and
in fact I still have recurring
nightmares where I'm in my childhood
bedroom and someone is coming to the
front door of them oh yeah do you have
dreams like that not really uh I have
Daydreams like I'll just think about
like somebody knocking on the door
trying to get trying to get the door
open but I don't know I hate your hands
Mark everything you're saying is like so
severe really I didn't know this was
that crazy but yeah
we got broken in all the time it was
just became kind of normal I mean our
Bandit our stairwell with this big
spiral staircase going up to the second
floor it had no railing so I would just
go every day like that was normally in a
big window with duvetine flapping it was
just became normal
did you ever were there ever any like
positive experiences about living in
like a fan in like an old mansion like
what were those good question no one's
ever asked that so I was a big
skateboarder we built a half pipe in the
backyard nobody cared we built uh like
rails and stuff to grind on in the big
part of it this huge parlor and we would
just skateboard in The Parlor when it
was too hot out or at night or whatever
so we could skate in the house we had a
basketball goal in our parlor so we
could play basketball in the house on a
hardwood floor uh uh sleepovers were
awesome yeah you know stuff like that we
climb under the house and look around
and go on little adventures was the vibe
that like because your parents were
Workaholics they weren't there so you
were just kind of like free to do
whatever you want totally okay I had a
similar thing at my best friend's house
where she
had a twin brother so her she always had
her friends over he always had his
friends over and it was her grandma's
house and her grandma didn't speak
English and was like always upstairs and
it was a big house so it was like we
always would just get to go there and do
whatever we wanted yeah there's like no
supervision that's the best yeah I mean
that's what home alone's all about you
know and so did you ever like
engage in like okay so basically I feel
like if I lived or if I was even just
for one day in this place that you you
grew up in I would like want to use my
imagination and feel like I'm this like
Rich Victorian princess like did you
ever like imagine cool things living
there all the time that was all I had
was imagination I would wear a cape I
remember I jumped off my balcony because
I thought I was a superhero and I hit my
head on my knee on the way down and
knocked myself out a construction worker
had to like bring me in the house it was
a whole thing but I wanted to be a
superhero because I wanted to fight
crime because all I knew was crime the
whole neighborhood was dangerous and the
house was getting broken into so I was
all in I had a utility belt I made I put
little pebbles in it like rocks and I
had a slingshot because I had to cope
with this this horrifying environment so
I wanted to be a superhero really bad
which a lot of comedians I've heard of
like wannabe superheroes oh I yeah my
one of my best friends in comedy this
guy John Campanelli he's a he has like a
Batman poster in his room there you go
there you go late 30s yes Seinfeld's
obsessed with Superman you know it's a
thing but so it sounds like you're you
and your parents
they watch sign
is like
that was probably I'm assuming was that
like your intro to like oh this is what
stand-up is I could do that yeah pretty
much yeah and they liked it which was
weird like whoa this is getting their
attention maybe if I do this I'll get
their attention hell yeah that is yes
totally same with like well for me
actually I would say more like growing
up we would go to family functions and
my dad was Jewish and we would always be
with my mom's side of the family because
my dad had me very late in life so all
this family was dead but like so we'd be
with my mom's family the the Gentiles
and my dad was like the silly Jewish guy
and he would always get laughs and so I
saw and like I was like oh that's a way
to like yeah
no
um so my dad is Russian Jewish and my
mom is Finnish oh interesting people
think polish because of the last name
but it ends in a y and that means
Russian you're right from what I've been
told there my dad is not like him and
both of his parents were born in America
so they don't like speak Russian there's
no you're a rusky I guess technically
yeah and I do Eileen like Russian sugar
baby in photos sometimes like in a good
angle
um
Okay so
you you're you said on Neil Brennan's
podcast that when your wife met your
parents it validated for you that they
were weird and I have the same
experience like when my fiance met my
parents
even actually like when my college
friends met my parents they it's like oh
this is not normal this is weird do you
know what the weirdness is about them
sure yeah well there's so many things
how long is this but my mom will do a
thing where she won't respond and it's
not in a mean way she just won't give
you any interaction or response so
you'll she'll go uh how was your show
yesterday and I'll go oh it was great I
got a heckled by this guy he threw a
bottle at me and she'll just stare at
you and you're like nothing on the
bottle I got through a bottle at me you
can't give me any so I think I also with
comedy the whole thing is response it's
just joke laugh joke laugh so I love
that because I need that response from
large groups of people because I didn't
get it from them
yes okay also relate to that
um I the first time I ever went out to
dinner with my fiance and his parents
they were like laughing at all the
things he was saying and I literally
thought it was physically impossible for
your own parents to find you funny I
thought there was like something
genetically where like yes they can't
and
it was just mind-blowing and okay
another thing too like I sorry I will
make this all about me no no we'll go
nuts because it's better
I remember seeing a commercial when I
was like in elementary school for like
Hasbro or some game company and it was
like get Monopoly for your family for
your next family game night and I was
like
what is fantastic
right right I felt so betrayed
um okay wait so what else is weird I
know what you mean though because I
would go to friend's house and had
pictures of them all over the like the
family photos and they're at Disney
World I was like your parents took you
to Disney World that's hey who would
carve out what kind of parent would
carve out like a week to go to Florida
that blew my mind my parents were just
working we didn't go to Disneyland but
yeah all kinds of weird stuff uh what
else is weird about my parents it seems
like yeah go ahead well my dad was was
always bottomless okay walking around
the house just like it was a comfort
thing a lot of genital a lot of male
genitalia swinging around the Norman
household
um and you have a sibling older brother
wait so what is he like the same as you
is he like this was crazy or is he yeah
he's kind of stuck to his own thing he
was a like a dungeon dragons goth guy
like he dealt with in a different way I
went out and like you know vandalized
and got drunk and he went in went cocoon
he like stayed in his room put the black
[__] on the Windows dyed his hair wore
or Pinger a fingernail painting [__]
yeah black fingernails and just went in
like chat rooms you know and I went out
he went in okay I like comedy and he
loves numbers he loves computers he
loves uh kind of he's a computer
programmer now how much older is he than
you two years so not that different and
you it seems like maybe you're not
you're not that close we're kind of like
co-workers you know this love there but
yeah we're so different I'm goofball and
he's serious yeah and he's got two kids
and they live in Wisconsin and
so another thing I very strongly related
to which is I'm newly reobsessed with
this topic because I'm basically having
trouble sleeping I have always struggled
with it going like bedtime was always
like I don't want it to come I'm so
scared of it and I think a lot of it has
to do with like so I actually like I
need others to be awake when I'm asleep
so so when I went to bed at night
everyone was already asleep and I hated
the idea of this like quiet house where
I'm the only one awake because then I
felt like I have to be the one that's
like on alert to see what's going on and
anyways so I two years ago I started
not smoking weed but using weed like
eating it that's what I do really yeah
okay I recently am trying to stop I know
is it bad as a side effects well I don't
want to like see activate sister I can
take it we when did you start using it I
don't know eight months ago oh really
yeah but it helps no it is like so okay
weed solved so many of my problems it
helped me with sleep it helped me relax
I think for the first time in my life
like I learned what it felt like to
relax and weirdly I didn't realize this
until I stopped using it but it was like
helping my digestive issues oh sure so
the reason that I stopped was because I
did hear that it's like it does age your
brain faster oh really and it's the
brain whoa and if you're getting your
dopamine from drugs
you're not getting it from like effort
this is I'm getting into a little bit of
a tangent but I'm really trying to focus
right now in my life on like getting my
rewards and my pleasure from effort
because I don't know if you've
experienced this but
I feel like when I first started stand
up I loved it and I got pleasure from
doing it right like after a good set I
got like that high in that buzz and then
as time went on I kind of got less
interested and which is another thing I
want to talk to you about because you
seem like you've never lost interest in
it and um then it was all about like
being done and getting high after and so
that's why I'm cutting back but anyways
that's why now I'm having more trouble
sleeping anyway anyway so what to talk
about fascinating
do so right now you're using weight to
sleep and that's how just to sleep not
the dopamine thing like I hate being
high oh okay I just like it to help me
sleep because it kind of shuts me down a
little do you eat it or what do you I do
a little gummy okay and very low I'm a
real lightweight okay and so are has
that like solved your sleep issues for
it helps for sure yeah because on Neil's
you said you were taking some like
illegal I'm taking a thing called
oh [__] it's a schizophrenia drug do you
still need that I take now I usually
take a full one now I take half of one
and the weed and it seems to be working
so I'm taking less of the drug but I'm
still taking some of it when you don't
have that or like what is it like what's
the experience of going to bed without
that like well for me it's the mental
it's all my brain just goes and it
usually tends to go to a bad place so
I'm just laying there like clock ticking
going like this person hates me I
shouldn't have said that that was bad
what am I doing with my life you're
stupid you know whatever thoughts yeah
thoughts which I was gonna ask you why
but I think I already know why you see
problems it's because people broke into
your house that in the bed wedding
because the bedwetting sleep man equaled
embarrassment yeah you know so I think
that has some tie-in I really want to
conquer the challenge of sleep and I
don't know I if you're using weed though
I feel like that's I'm like happy for
you and that's great especially if it's
like a low dose news low dose and the
doctor I asked the doctor and he said go
for it I don't want to take that away
from you respect I'm currently like
trying to go on my own
what what is it called when people do
that sober I guess yeah cold turkey
something
um and
I'm also uh I'll dabble with like a
little melatonin oh that's good stuff
but that's also not good for you really
but it really works Oh I thought that
was the the one natural good one
no when it's like you think it is but
then when you go a level deeper into
Wellness like the LA hot girl level of
wellness it's like everything is bad and
you have to be really careful yeah but
these Gales are using Botox and fake
tits and uh uh you know nose jobs so
what the hell do they know that is a
really good Counterpoint for some that
okay that is noted all right so
okay sleep issues you're using weed oh
do you okay
have you ever lost interest in stand up
ooh it comes and goes and I think it's
like a relationship uh you got to keep
it spicy so uh for me I still love it
because it's so hard like writing a new
joke is [__] hard and then you gotta
figure it out on stage and make it work
and get laughs and bombing is so painful
so to me the fact that I can't crack
comedy is what keeps me in it does that
make sense yeah totally and the rewards
I think get better like I just uh taped
a Netflix hour I'm doing theaters now
not to brag but I'm just saying like
it's so much nicer because those Open
Mic days were hell
um bar shows getting heckled you know
all that [__] was hell no one listening
the TVs are on behind you so I can
really appreciate it uh putting all this
work in and then there are rewards at
the end like you had the weed reward
right I'm trying to use the career
reward yeah yes that's like the track
that I'm trying to get back on where I
actually care about those things yeah I
think that that is what will keep a
person in a game like that and in the
like excited about the creative career
Esther what are these cool fancy tall
boys I'm seeing everywhere okay it's
liquid death and I am I feel like they
answered my death prayers because they
just launched three new Iced Teas they
have Grim leafer rest in Peach and
armless Palmer and they're so delicious
I'm
like
I love liquid death because I just love
the convenience of the tall boy can I
love popping open a can of water people
looking at me like I'm crazy it just it
just for me adds to the brand of myself
oh and these cans of iced tea are
healthy and like a lot of those other
Iced Teas that are loaded with sugar
these are only lightly sweetened with
six grams of Premium Agave only 30
calories and provide a micro dose of 30
milligrams of caffeine per tallboy it's
actually awesome I don't like when
drinks are too sugary these are like the
perfect level of a little sweet a little
tea and they're enhanced with B vitamins
as well
I appreciate that thank you for making
us pretty liquid death's new Iced Teas
are available now with free shipping at
Amazon and retailers near you as an
added bonus trash Tuesday listeners get
20 off their first liquid duck Peril
purchase available exclusively at
liquiddeath.com trash exclusions May
apply that's liquiddeath.com trash you
guys we love Lumi me and koyla have been
using it these past few months and were
obsessed and look the sun is shining the
birds are chirping and the spring air is
warm which means sweat is upon us
thankfully Lumi deodorant is here to
keep us smelling nice so we need it the
most and where we need it the most
actually we're talking pits privates and
Beyond let's face it our under underarms
aren't the only place we have odor no
big deal not embarrassing to share at
all
with best-selling scents like lavender
sage clean Tangerine fresh Alpine you'll
smell better than ever and they also
just launch new scents including mint
cucumber and soft powder sign me up
please I like that Lumi is
basically something you can put all over
your body it's skin safe aluminum free
clinically proven to control odor for up
to 72 hours so we're talking I'm taking
the weekend in Miami I I'm wiping my
body with Lumi I'm not doing anything
till I get home okay that covers me the
whole weekend and a special offer for
new customers they get five dollars off
Lumi starter pack with code trash
Tuesday at Lumi deodorant.com
so I did listen to a couple minutes of
your solo podcast and I was so glad that
I did because you talked about something
that I really
don't hear a lot of people talk about
which is like
you still bomb oh yeah all the time and
in my head I'm like no one who's good
bombs I'm the only person who bombs like
I'll I have gotten so used to things not
working that like when I go home and my
fiance is like how'd it go I'm like it
was fine he's like you bombed and I'm
like well I can't like think that or
I'll just stop doing it because I'm so
bad absorb it let it sink in it's gonna
hurt but it'll motivate you to kick ass
again I do get I get off on failing on
stage like I like I'm like oh I can
handle it and that makes me feel strong
and tough and it was just really
encouraging to hear that you're like
open to going up there and and failing
oh yeah because if you fail and come out
of it there's nothing better to me a new
idea working it will bomb also I used to
see Louis CK in the height of Louis like
pre-cancel bombing all day long and uh
it was like motivating for me because I
was like oh that's a great idea but it
didn't connect the audience didn't get
it and seeing this guy at this level
this was like when he was the guy and he
would bomb a lot and I remember being
like all right that gives me hope
because you you got a bomb and gives you
information like okay that's not good
that kind of works take that out you
know so you got to do it okay do you
deal with though the insecurity that
like what if some of the people are in
this crowd specifically because they're
a fan of mine and they want to see me
that is tough I hate that I hate it too
because I want to work out and they're
like oh I like this guy now he's not
that good [__] him and I don't feel like
that's a really good excuse to like keep
myself from growing yeah I'm like well
even if like one percent of the people
in this room it's just one percent that
like came because they are my fan like
that sucks it's so much pressure you do
not want to let someone down who likes
you feel the same way it kills me but
you gotta do it and you gotta think of
the long term the long term is you'll
have a special out in a year or whatever
and they'll see that and be like oh that
was great that's true like I've even had
people DM me and be like I saw you at
the comedy store you had Swagger up
there
like okay like I guess like at least if
I show them that yeah no no just just be
like I'm working out tonight you know or
say that up top just to give them a
little bit like oh okay this isn't her
normal stuff oh oh I didn't even think
to do that and some crowds love that
they're like oh we're getting to see the
inside [__] you know I would I know that
I certainly as like a nerdy person and a
fan of like creative people I would like
that experience more at least more than
when I've gone up and I've just like
been insecure and like delivered the old
boring jokes that I know works because
then I'm like not okay that's another
thing that that like since I've been in
New York and like really giving a [__]
about my stand-up it's like one of the
keys is being present on stage for me do
you feel like that's really important to
you definitely and I can get real very
robotic I'm I'm a [__] machine
autistic obviously so like you gotta
when the guy's talking just go hey stop
talking because I used to go don't ruin
your your momentum don't ruin your
Rhythm but it's better to just address
it yes being present is like again it's
kind of scary because yes if the it's
unknown and also if you're not
mentally active in the right way being
present can you can just like [__] it up
even more I don't know totally but it is
it's not worth doing I think if in the
long term if you're not like fully
present but also one last thing before
we move on I think you got to remind
yourself because we've all been there
the stand-up is kind of boring it's not
as fun as it used to be I used to be a
janitor I used to move furniture I used
to work on a construction site sweeping
up sheetrock we get to do comedy you got
to remember that even when you're like I
got nothing out of that it didn't really
get me off just think I still get to do
it though I still get to be a comic and
go on the road and tell jokes and do
[__] like this where you sit down and
talk in front of cameras you got to be
grateful for that that is a really good
mindset it's hard to have that though
because I do feel so much shame in being
a comedian really what do you mean well
it's like first of all even just now the
fact that we're having a semi-serious
conversation about stand up on a podcast
it makes me want to die it's so cringe
but I do think we're actually we're
getting somewhere yeah we're not being
too pretentious we're not like let me
tell you about the art form and here's
how I break down we're not doing that
[__] right like I think though that
actually what I'm saying is different
from what you're saying but what the
thing that makes me so cringe is when
people do take it too seriously and they
think that they're like curing cancer no
you're not telling jokes like we don't
want to be that but I I think what
you're saying is actually the opposite
it's like hey this is silly and fun yeah
and like let's be appreciative of it
that is I'm like
I guess that is cool because I used I
was a Johnny Rockets waitress yeah there
you go I was I but that I was also very
performative for me so it's not quite
like sweeping up but you know when you
get you get sick of your boyfriend or
your husband or whatever you're going
with here
fiance and you get sick of him and then
another girl hits on them and you're
kind of like oh geez and you get pissed
at her and then you're like wait I like
this this is my guy [__] you [__] get
out of here you [__] you know that's
what stand up but you got to remind
yourself like I got a good thing here
and I want to keep it because if when
the pandemic hit it got taken away I was
CR I didn't realize how much I relied on
it and needed it for a purpose in life
and a goal and all that [__] so yeah
that was an eye-opener okay
when I'm now that I'm back in it and
like thinking about ideas and jokes and
trying things like I noticed that my
anxiety has been greatly reduced because
I've realized that I'm a person that I
need some sort of a creative Outlet or
like a problem because if I don't have
that
it's going to be intrusive thoughts
ruminating thoughts it's gonna like my
brain will go circle circle yes dot dot
whether it's about a creative passionate
thing or if it's about like oh my God
like that person doesn't like me or you
know I [__] this up forever
so I do think that I don't remember why
I got to that point but it's like to
fight the intrusive thoughts it's like
just throw some yes creative Spirit on
it you gotta have a goal and it's good
you know when you have that thing where
you're like oh I have two shows tonight
you kind of get that nervousness like oh
[__] I gotta like kind of prepare or
mentally get ready that's good for
people yeah everyone wants to avoid that
part of life that little discomfort lean
into it go for it and you'll be happier
after otherwise you're gonna just sit
online all day and that's going to make
you way more [__] up yeah but the
whole country's doing basically I'm
trying to think like if someone is not
like a person who has stand up like what
is a what are other creative Outlets
that they like can focus on like I'm
just trying to think like if it was the
pandemic and I couldn't do which also
when I go back to LA like I won't be
able to do it as much as I'm doing it
here which side note you do you know
that you're kind of like the gold
standard for like stand-up Obsession and
like how many sets people do yeah like
you're like the unwell example it's like
no one can feel like they're doing
enough because someone could always be
like well look at how many sets Mark
Norman does but I'm also filling a hole
and I just love it and I think and it
also has people a lot of people hate me
for that why well there because it
shames them they're like I didn't do any
sets people go well he did three and
you're like oh well [__] that guy no you
always need someone like her head like I
think that's a good and it's also
impressive that you've maintained that
reputation for like 10 years that's why
I'm like how are you still so into it
but I hear it's I get it yeah it is fun
it's good
um
so okay and what else am I doing you
know is receiving compliments
uncomfortable yeah totally okay that I
recently read from this like
psychologist uh that
it's because it's likely because your
parents never complimented you so it's
like a weird uncomfortable thing
definitely yeah I have that too I'm like
if someone comments me I'm like oh I'm
disgusting like yeah same say I went to
film school and I had to write or make
this movie at the end of it and I showed
it to my parents and my mom goes this is
bad and I remember being like ah damn
that hurt like hell but that's that
feels still feels familiar
Okay so a couple like maybe eight years
ago or whatever I did this pilot
um for HBO that was about me going back
to my high school and auditioning for
the musical like as a grown adult
and we like filmed documentary stuff in
my parents house and we caught my mom on
a hot mic like didn't know she was being
recorded and she was like this is really
sad
this is gonna be really bad oh my God
that's so Finnish
you know holy moly oh so you're familiar
with the Finnish culture sure I've been
there it's it's you've been to Finland I
have I did a gig there yeah whoa I went
for Bert Kreischer there years ago did
they laugh barely yeah got a lot of
comments after but it was like they're
very stiff stoic people yes that's how
my mom is like like very dry and like
all monotone and like nothing is funny
or you know yeah that's like you fall
down that's right right exactly
um
okay would it be accurate to say that
you have a hard time looking at people
yes
I can do it during a pod because I'm I'm
aware I'm on camera but otherwise I
don't like it why not it's just too
intense yeah you know the eye contact
it's it's it's heavy yeah it is hard I
wonder if that also goes back to like
childhood like sometimes me my friends
will laugh but like we do stand up
because like Mommy didn't look at us so
I don't know like I said my lady wants
it in the bedroom and I I just I can't
do it I look at her nose or her ass or
the cat
I struggle with that too like yeah icon
some sometimes there's a good time for
it and sometimes I can't do it yeah
sometimes I'm like I need to
disassociate
um
uh okay oh
just try travel for a stand up this is
the thing that I struggle with and I
wanted to know how you feel about it
does it get exhausting do you get like
homesick or do you actually like that
part of it in any way like and if so how
or why I I obviously I hate the airport
I hate the [__] security and all that
but I love being on a if you got a
decent seat when you're on a flight and
you're kind of like oh I'm safe here
yeah you know like no one can bother me
no one can call me I do love that
um what do you do when you're in that
I'm a big podcast I'll bring a book I'll
take a nap I just I watch the movie I'm
like oh we got movies this is great I
feel like a kid again I feel like oh I'm
locked in and no one can bother me yeah
that is kind of nice which is ironic
because I'm in the middle of the sky and
I'm like I feel so safe but uh I love
the road I love hotels I love being in
Oklahoma I love being in Denver I just
like being somewhere else and we do more
as comics than most people do in a year
like you know in a weekend I mean like
we'll go to like three different cities
I'll rent a car I'm doing Montana next
weekend I'm so excited I get to see
Montana I've never been there I can see
the mountain ranges who the [__] lives
in Montana I'll meet some people so you
will like make the most of it and like
all the things and eat the food yeah and
then I go both ways so I'll be too
hungover and I'm like [__] Kansas City
I'm closing the curtains and I'm jerking
off all day right you know so I have
both but I love it yeah like I do think
I would I'm assuming is it is it safe to
assume that like the times where you are
taking advantage of the city you like
leave feeling better and yes yeah yes
exactly I do struggle with that though
it is really hard to motivate getting
out of the hotel room especially for me
when it's hanging over me that like I'm
gonna be doing a long set at night I
want to be the most energized version of
myself makes sense but I do think that's
like a lie and I would be just as good
if I want to fight like that's just like
unhealthy because you do get energy from
using energy like your body kind of
picks it up but do you drink I don't oh
see that that's huge that's a huge leg
up because I'm putting poison in my body
every night and it's definitely wearing
on me let's discuss that okay okay do
you drink after you're set yeah never
before and what does that do for you I
think it's a come down it's a treat yeah
like oh we did all these shows we sold
merch we shook hands we took photos
let's have a [__] cocktail take the
edge off kick your feet up and how drunk
do you get ah well I like to feel it you
know I'm not gonna have one so I want to
get a little banged up I won't go black
out I used to but I don't do that
anymore but I'll definitely get pretty
tuned up and does that not help you
sleep horrible for the sleeping
horrible I mean you're getting horrible
sleep and you then you wake up your
whole next day's ruined then you feel
shame and sadness and embarrassment so
it's just piling putting gasoline on
this already anxious fire I got going on
in my head but I love it interesting
okay it sounds like for you alcohol is
like what weed has been for yeah where
it's like oh my God I can't wait to do
it it's going to relax me it's going to
be so much fun like yeah I which is why
I'm trying to put a pause on it but I
don't yeah that's but the alcohol is way
worse so all the [__] you're like oh
weed it makes your brain age all that
alcohol is that times a thousand so
you're good do you ever think like I
don't always want to do and I'm not by
the way I want to be clear I'm not
trying to shame you no I think it's cool
I think it's genuinely curious because I
would I want to keep smoking weed I love
it so much but yeah do you ever
do you are you ever like oh I gotta stop
this I should stop this do you ever have
like those internal conversations of
course and what are they like all the
time I mean by the way don't don't hold
back I'm an open casket I will tell you
anything and I'm never gonna be offended
but
I do love it and I know it's horrible
for me and it's definitely ruined me and
a lot of you know I've had DUIs I've
wrecked cars I've fist fights all this
horrible [__] said crazy [__] I
shouldn't have said but now I've kind of
gotten the reins on a little bit and I
love it so much that I don't abuse it oh
okay you know but it's still bad
so I've definitely slowed down I used to
black out once a week twice a week maybe
and now I don't black out ever and I
drink only on the weekends I think when
I have kids I'm gonna cut it out all
completely okay so if you're doing it
only on the weekends that does feel more
reasonable to me because I was doing
weed I literally got high every night
for two years wow so that is at least
like only on the weekends seems great
all right if I can that would be great
for me yeah yeah so okay and you think
if you have kids you'd stop
yeah the I just stay with a friend he's
got two kids and I slept on his couch
and I was drinking every night and I
wanted to kill myself every morning
because they're up at six a.m they're
pushing you they're poking you and
you're you want to be like get out of
here we should have aborted you but I'm
like you know just just so hungover with
kids it makes you realize like I
couldn't do this if I these were my kids
right it like physically wouldn't work
yeah your wife drink yeah she's a booze
hound which is what we we get along we
go out we drink together that's fun yeah
it's super fun and the sex is a sloppy
[__] show and we all have a good time
but
yeah again maybe with the kids it'll
slow it down
foreign
and book doctors who are patient
reviewed take your insurance are
available when you need them and treat
almost every condition Under the Sun
okay have you been stewing about a
health problem you have
you almost resort to texting your group
chat and get your friend's opinion
you're extremely unlikely to find a
quality medical advice in your group
chat but you can find it from a Doctor
on Doctor thousands of medical
professionals on ZocDoc are there to
help you they listen like a friend and
they give you expert care need look at
it absolutely love ZocDoc I've used it
twice now I had a toothache at 11 PM
I got a doctor's appointment for the
next day at 10 A.M
um my teeth dog or hurt I got I had a
beautiful
woman lost my teeth for me I had a
cavity filled I had
I got a free toothbrush it was Heaven it
was the easiest thing to do I loved it I
knew it was going to be a great
experience because I read all the
reviews and it was incredible I went to
a neurologist where my cluster headaches
I had reached a breaking point where I
was like I've got to go see an expert I
was able to get one two days after my
appointment after my first ZocDoc
inquiry and I was able to go get on
steroids try to kick these headaches I
mean it was just really an amazing
experience I knew they took my insurance
it was just so easy it was
it was incredible
um I am such a zoc talk supporter you
guys got to try it out and it's
completely free for you so there's
really no excuse zotdoc is the only free
app that lets you find and book doctors
who are patient reviewed take your
insurance are available when you need
them and treat almost every condition
under the sun no more Dr roulette or
scouring the internet for questionable
reviews with zogdoc you have a trusted
guide to connect you to your favorite
doctor you haven't even met yet millions
of people use octoc's free app to find
and book a doctor in their neighborhood
who's patient reviewed and fits their
needs and schedule just right when
you're not feeling your best and just
trying to hold it together finding great
care shouldn't take up all of your
energy that's where ZocDoc comes in
using their free app that millions of
users rely on me included you can find
the right doctor that meets your needs
and fits your schedule book an
appointment with a few TAPS in their app
and start feeling better faster it was
act on go to zocdoc.com trash and
download the ZocDoc app for free then
find and book a top rated doctor today
many are available within 24 hours
that's
zocdoc.com trash
zocdot.com trash this show is sponsored
by better help getting to know yourself
can be a lifelong process especially
because we are always growing and
changing every single day first of all
if you're gonna date someone
and they're not in therapy ick vomit run
away which means you need to be in
therapy so that you're not an ick vomit
runaway situation
and I think better help is the perfect
place to start if you haven't done
therapy before it just makes it so easy
for a beginner right like it's all
online it's very popular it's accessible
it's affordable it's such a good way to
just dip your toe into the therapy game
um and you can discover your potential
With Better Health visit betterhelp.com
trash Tuesday today to get 10 off your
first month that's better help
help.com slash trash Tuesday
[Music]
how do you function when you did not get
sleep oh it's bad it's bad a cranky your
brain is slower and as a comedian you
got to be on you got to be with it so
it's just it's just your whole body just
feels shittier so uh when I get a good
seven hours I'm a I'm a pistol right
yeah no like not getting sleep and then
having to work is so scary and then that
anxiety will like keep me yes longer
because anxiety oh my God I'm only gonna
get this many years and then it gets
less and less exactly I think like if I
I just got advice from someone that was
like
just forget about that you'll be fine on
four hours like tell yourself you'll be
okay I don't know if that'll work but
well I heard of two tricks one from a
smart meditative yoga douche he told me
that all these thoughts that are going
by look at it like traffic and just let
the thoughts go by like cars don't let
them don't grab one and think about it
just go oh yeah that is that is shitty
and Let It Go by look at it like cars on
the road and I was like that's pretty
good and that does help and then the
one breath in one breath out do that
three times that actually helps oh so
just lay there at night going
yeah and it does help breathing it's so
embarrassing but it does help it helps
yeah it's embarrassing to admit
something's so basic and I know it would
actually like be a useful tool but I
think in this technologically advanced
digital world baby I think we gotta come
back to the The Roots a little do you
find like that you're a little burnt out
on like screens and yeah oh yeah yeah oh
yeah what are the things that you'd
rather be doing with your time or that
you're trying to do more of as opposed
to like scrolling well I used to write
every day for an hour and change every
single day like okay what and what was
that routine like like morning coffee
like what was it like well uh paper or
just like brain walking well walking for
me it's all walking and like I was a
psycho when I first started comedy
comedy was so hard and I was so bad at
it that I would use my lunch break as a
janitor and I would write in the boiler
room alone for an hour and not eat but I
would write and I got some great
material out of it and I kind of learned
how to write jokes but it was tough you
know just that motivation you know
because you want to just go to Subway
and get a foot long and [__] a kid but
you gotta go that was a Subway joke but
um and now and then I was writing every
day when I quit having a day job I was
writing every day and I was really I
felt like I was putting out good
material and then you kind of start
coasting and then you're like ah [__] it
I'm hungover I'm not gonna write and now
I look at a screen instead of writing
and I'm like I'm not getting anything
out of this I'm watching a fist fight
yeah and a deer getting shot or whatever
so I've tried to cut that out and just
go to the writing again or the gym or
whatever it is and what
he says you're walking I I take an hour
and I go all right it's 106. so I'm
gonna write till 206 and I walk and pace
and talk like a psycho with a hairbrush
in my hand and if anybody saw it I'd
kill myself because it's so embarrassing
and now my lady works from home so I
have to go on the roof and do it and
every now and then I'll be on my roof of
my apartment in New York and talking and
somebody will come up to like water the
plants and they're like
sorry and they'll go back down the
stairs backwards and I'm like oh that
was embarrassing because I'm like Uber's
weird huh and I look like such a douche
that is actually so much more human than
like being caught jerking off like
way worse wait so and then if you say
something that you think is good you
write it down and I write it down and it
gets the it gets the brain flowing and
it makes your stand up more natural
sounding I think than if you're like
here's the setup here's the punchline
but if you talk it out I feel like you
can find way more angles that was always
something that got in the way of me
having more material at a faster pace
which was the like I could never sit
down with the pen and paper and write
joke same it's like I wish like I had
realized that 10 years ago but that was
never gonna work that's not the art form
like the it's a speaking art form and
it's like a the way you say things is
also part of the writing process yes you
can't again like sit if you're writing a
book yes you can sit and type it or
whatever but like
that is I've never it's so humiliating
I've never thought to do it but yeah
you're like inspiring me to like get a
hairbrush and like that is I like so
much respect for how embarrassing that
is and that you're willing to do it and
well it's hard to start too because you
have to go like what am I doing walk
around so you have to go I know I'm
stupid I'm holding a hairbrush you say
dumb [__] just to get you out of it and
out of your head and moving on with it
okay how did you cope with the
humiliation and pain of wetting the bed
with the fellow adult that you had sex
with the night before well it's like we
cope with anything else you make a joke
out of it uh you try to blame it on them
every now and then but yeah I would just
go I did a lot of apologizing a lot of
jokes and then I would do the thing
where I would pay for their uh dry
cleaning and I'd buy them flowers that
was like my that was like my [__]
Derek Jeter uh what is that you know he
[__] a girl and gave her like a bag
like a goodie bag oh do you know that no
yeah he would give you like a bouquet
and an Edible Arrangement and a gift bag
that's kind of smart yeah because it
also stops women from being like you
know what he did this to me well well
maybe he did but we don't know or it
just stops the angry feelings of like
hey this guy used me like no no we had a
great night here's a gift yeah right you
definitely don't want that is one thing
where it's like I when people hook up
and then the guy is like mean afterwards
oh that is weird you gotta like at least
be polite we all know whatever okay so
how did the women react to that this is
what I need to know most were pretty
forgiving like obviously you have a girl
like oh Jesus are you [__] serious
and it's so embarrassing and you want to
kill yourself but uh most of them were
like ah it's all right just uh get out
of here or whatever like can you can you
wash my sheets and I go sure you got it
so it was usually pretty good but as
good as it can get there was never like
a oh it's okay I love piss you know it
was never that obviously but
uh it was I've bought a new couch for a
lady once I mean I try to do my part and
redeem it and when did how long ago did
that stop happening well that was most
of most of college so whenever I got out
of college so not as like an adult
comedian not really no maybe once or
twice in the last 20 years
how are you still afraid of that like 15
years that does that still haunt you and
live with you the like fear of waking up
and having wet the bed not really unless
I'm hammered if I'm really hammered I'm
like I might wet the bed tonight but it
was all booze related okay because I did
as a kid I got over it and then the
blacking out would trigger it again
I once the first time I hooked up with
this guy that I like had a crush on for
a long time
I had my got my period like the first
night I slept over and I also told me a
joke I was like oh I guess I was a
virgin
um but that's great that's a great joke
but it was it's it's such a it's brutal
it's a really painful feeling but I
assume he was cool with it he wasn't
mean he wasn't like oh my God it's
totally fine yeah not like the I feel
like like the guy I'm with now he would
not
he would have been like who cares but I
that that guy was kind of like
it's fine with like a face uh that's uh
I never got that it's a natural thing I
get it it's vulnerable and bloody but
like why make a lady feel bad I think he
maybe didn't like me that much oh okay
okay well that's different separate
issue oh did you ever like have cool
experiences in cool cemeteries in New
Orleans oh well we used to go there and
drink a lot and uh you know tell ghost
stories and hang out because they were
pretty
you know vacant obviously at night yeah
and our our cemeteries are crazy because
it floods obviously so they build
mausoleums so we don't have graves in
New Orleans no I've seen Graves there
well they're grave stones but they're
actually they're built up they're a
little like uh they're not six feet
underground are they above ground some
are above ground and some are just like
these Stone
blocks with a body in it because you
can't if it's coffins they'll fly flop
up during the the floods and then
they'll you know scatter all over the
city that's how bad the flooding is
you've seen Katrina footage right so we
have mausoleums mostly okay so you can
sit on them and hang out and jump on
them were you affected by Katrina I was
not really I mean our house got [__]
up a little bit we lost the car but I
was in LSU an hour away and we were fine
but my parents had to stay with us for a
couple days and that was brutal
do you feel like your parents are proud
of you now I think now they are took a
while what is like the vibe like are
they like oh my God this isn't because
my parents now I think are so like they
thought I was such a nothing that like
any tiny accomplishment I've ever had
they were so shocked by so it was like
such a even I remember like
the first time I was on I did remember
correct Ferguson I did a late night set
on Kirk Ferguson and I still have this
email from my dad that is like
I this like I cannot believe how far
you've like how much you it was that's
huge it was but I look back and I'm like
they really thought I could do nothing
right right do you but so they are so
overly proud now that it almost to a
point where it makes me uncomfortable
because I'm like
this what so you only like me because I
have Hollywood success which is fine
like I'm so desperate for it that I'll
take it anyway but deep down I'm like
you know it's like my mom wants me to
buy her a pair of UGGs like what what
who who really what do you really like
yeah do you I get that do they feel is
it like an overwhelmingly proud or is it
just like a little bit of a pat on the
back it's uh like wow how about that you
know
um but I get what you're saying but I I
do think when it hit home that's when it
really connected with him like I was
doing the theater in my in New Orleans
and it sold out and they were like oh
wow this is crazy like when it's in
their town and they can see it with
their eyes it's not like I got to The
Cellar or I I did this show and you know
Poughkeepsie that went great they're
like I don't know what that means but
when it's in the city they live in
they're like oh this is real and people
are hitting them up for tickets and
they're like oh [__] when it it came
home to roost yeah and that's literally
when it they uh they
open their eyes to it when I shot my
special I did
um like part of it it was just like
documentary documentary footage of me
and my parents and they came to watch me
headline Gotham and whoa and I'm like
there's I think it's in the special
where I'm like Dad like are you proud of
me like I'm headlight in Gotham God I
could never do that and he literally
goes well it's not Madison Square Garden
oh that's classic that's a great line
wait why could you never do that I could
never go dead are you proud of me wait
really no no that
saying I yeah I like I'll go fall out
that's great that's I think that's
healthy I'm too like I don't want to
make him feel weird or I don't want to
feel weird but I will say that maybe
because there's cameras rolling that
like makes it easier because sure this
is all kind of silly sure of course of
course but what and but that Garden line
is that's a perfect button on the whole
special I mean that sums it all up
they're like the best jokes in my
special were said by my dad on accident
for sure was he trying to be funny
that I don't think so that's even better
wait where'd you grow up I grew up in
Skokie it's a suburb of Chicago oh
Skokie you've heard of it I've heard of
it I don't know anything about it I've
heard it's a funny words it was a funny
word it's the world's largest Village
and it's famous for a KKK March hey
there you go yes because we have the
highest number of Holocaust Survivors so
the KKK chose our town our village to
march in to sort of like really really
stick it to Jewish people yeah you hear
that black folk you got the you got off
easy on that one yeah
I think people forget that the KKK hates
Jews and Mexicans everybody hate
everybody except for I think they hate
uh
non-catholics like they even hate
certain white people with different
religions
okay so yeah and same with the Holocaust
Holocaust said
uh gay people it had black people that's
true Jews very inclusive the show but
there are others yeah she was still a
show with the Holocaust black people
still the show with the KKK
so do you wait do you have any Chicago
gigs coming up I just shot my special
there at the Vic theater I love Chicago
that's awesome great town did you eat
anything exciting I had the beef I had
the primantis or whatever not for me
that's Pittsburgh Portillo's Portillos
yeah I had that I had a this guy
Professor Pizza he's like the Chicago
staple he came out and cooked pizza in
the green room
um what else we had we had a bunch of
did you have a hot dog had a hot dog
went to Lake Michigan saw the green
Rivers during St Patty's I'm the only
douche who filmed on St Patty's the
crowd was hammered the whole time oh
yeah
College University of Illinois and
Urbana Champaign they have this holiday
called unofficial and it's unofficial St
Patrick's Day it's the Friday before and
all the kids start have you heard of
this that's when I was there the Friday
before the they start drinking like at 8
A.M 8 A.M I saw them why is that okay
well I'm from New Orleans Mardi Gras is
the same way okay and every tailgate you
know they get hammered at like 11 A.M I
was such a nerd in college because I
hated it that everyone was drinking
obviously because I was just like
jealous that they weren't paying
attention to me but I was always like in
my head I was like you guys think that
you're gonna drink and then just quit
when you get out like you're gonna be
you're not gonna be able to go to work
either you'll be too drunk anyway I was
a [__] nerd
um jeez yeah I know right narc over here
wait okay so we shot your special at the
Vic at the Vic yeah went well I love
that town I would put it number three is
the best comedy City what's one and two
well I think New York
is up there but audience wise I think
Denver might be number one laugh wise is
that like based on the Comedy Works or
other places Comedy Works the Paramount
it just the audience there really get it
and I think more specials have been shot
there than anywhere else I always
thought that that was literally just
Comedy Works it was like a great room
but you're saying it's audience related
yeah yeah I did the arena there with
Schumer and that was killer she did her
special there
um whoa Rogan has done a special Dimitri
Martin David tell uh uh Greg Geraldo
Dana Gould like so many specials are
done in Denver what are your Vibes on
Philly in Boston I feel like oh I love
those those are both great the Wilbur's
grade and anything Philly I love
now as a person who's lived in La for 14
years and now I've been in New York for
two months for the first time I have to
say and I I know this might be like
hacky like new girl in town but I'm so
remarkably energized by the city like
physically creatively mentally like I
love it so much to the fact where I'm
like this was a clerical error I was
never supposed to live what did I do wow
and I'm curious like do you also feel
because you've lived here a long time do
you still feel those things I'm saying
or do I sound a little bit like New Girl
in Town well that's the thing about New
York it is energetic it's great it's fun
but it's also like that that crazy gal
who's fun in bed but there's also tons
of other red flags you know the hobos
the Kooks the [__] the the subway is
not running at the right time uh you
land in New York and you're like oh good
to be home [__] I can't get an Uber or
the Uber's 800 or I got shanked on the
[__] air train you know there's
always something with this city it just
[__] you right in the ass it finds a
way so it is great it is awesome it is
culturally diverse and we got every kind
of music and food and the city is
beautiful
but it is Hell in a lot of ways it's not
natural way to live
the tiny Apartments the freezing cold
you know the trash piling up the rats
you know there's a lot of downfall okay
yes true I can't see after two months
that becoming a little bit more yes
enjoy it while you're here it is a great
I I I'm gonna raise kids here so you're
here to stay I'm here yeah do you ever
go to La and feel like oh I could or
would live here I love LA but I love to
visit and I'd say the same with Austin
Austin is beautiful it's great the
weather is amazing the beach in La is
great but
I feel like La I
I see through it within like a week I'm
like all right I'm out I got it I'm
going back to a real City what does that
mean what you see what do you see I
think the people are a little vapid I
think the it's a lot of chasing
celebrity and not about real I feel like
it's not about like real talent or goals
some people have talent but it's not
about like oh I wanna
work on this art form or I want to I
want to progress at this it's like I
gotta get a sitcom or I gotta get famous
or I gotta be a tick tock whatever and
you feel that when you meet people and
you feel like are they looking at me or
like looking through me uh then you show
them you hey there's my wife and they go
well she can't help me [__] her so then
you're like oh man you guys aren't like
real people anymore and no one really is
from there it feels like these are all
very accurate there are generalizations
but they're obviously generalizations
for a reason but I would my counter
point would be like
is there really none of that here
because here of course we have it too
okay because I was gonna say it's like
New York and LA are both cities where
people are like trying to make it yes
and like I try not to shame that because
I do get it but at the same time
what I'm feeling here is so positive and
different in the other direction that I
have to like give validity to what
you're saying because it's like yeah I
feel like I I like I literally went to
dinner in Brooklyn with four women I've
never strangers really like and it was
this girl like came to my show and she
seemed cool and was like almost like
when you meet a person and it's like
kind of like a flirty connection yeah we
like had that and we're like oh let's
keep it going and then that's great and
I'm like that maybe is not so typical
but it is definitely
a New York energy thing definitely
definitely like I'm I don't know there's
just it seems also like people are
smarter here and again that could be
really a basic blanket thing that is
made out of nonsense but also I'm saying
it I like it I like well I think La is
beautiful it has its its pluses but I do
think the isolation
uh hurts yes Community aspect that is
that's your car you're in your house
you're not connecting and you're not and
because connecting takes a little bit of
effort and in La it's so comfortable
maybe not so much anymore but it's so
comfortable that you're like I don't
want to do that I can go home and smoke
weed yes in my cool apartment
and that is a problem and I think that's
why in La like I lean more towards being
kind of like a sad mope right here
I'm not yeah I mean again it's getting
hacky of like L.A versus I get it but
also no I'm I'm fully engaged and on
board so if people are like you guys are
lame it's like we know yeah I mean how
many times in La do people go we gotta
get lunch and you never do totally but
in New York I feel like you get the
lunch and I hate that because I came
from a Chicago where it's like I oh my
God a thing that annoyed me so much
about like the culture there when like
the first few years I was there people
would text me I miss you and I'd be like
that asked me to hang out
that's a great Point you're not allowed
to text me I miss you yeah ask me to
hang out I'm right here that's a that
could be a bit thing oh write it down
writing it down speaking it into a
hairbrush um mark thank you so much for
chatting and where are you going next
where can people come and see you first
I want to say your mom texted she said
this episode sucks I said it was really
sad now
um I'm all over the road I'm going to
Australia uh to do a bunch of gigs there
so that I'm excited about that okay that
this is random but I did gigs
on a strong time ago they were terrible
because I was not good but uh coffee and
Thai food in Australia
so good I'm down all right bring it on
love Ty and I love coffee uh so yeah
markdormancomedy.com I have a podcast
called uh we might be drunk and Tuesdays
with stories and then you heard all over
the road which is my singular product
what is Tuesday's with stories that's me
and Joe list we will go on the road and
have adventures and then come back and
talk about it on Tuesday does that come
out every week every week so you have
three podcasts that come out every week
yeah it's a nightmare I feel so much
better I bet at times in my life I've
had four podcasts and it felt like a
human punch line yeah like culturally
represented in media is like a joke it's
like a girl with too many podcasts but
um I think right now I have two okay
last Tuesdays and my pleasure and I'm
gonna I'm playing The Wilbur this fall
that's one of the best rooms in the
country you're gonna have a blast oh
yeah great great theater it feels like a
club it's very intimate but it's still
1100 seats or whatever the hell oh my
God you're gonna love it I am excited so
for people listening I'm coming to Miami
Boston New York Atlanta and Raleigh you
can get tickets at Esther onice.com and
Mark where can people get tickets to see
you markdormancomedy.com and check out
one of his three podcasts yes please see
you guys next week thank you
[Music]
thank you
foreign